interview the vampire you did when you
were how old you were like 11 years old
11 years old and I've been doing I could
retire right now I'm like exactly ready
to now and I could retire long you've
started really early didn't do the
vampire you were 11 and it was your
first scream you had a scream kiss with
Brad Pitt yeah I were 11 I did although
I thought it was disgusting it was like
I was 11 it would have been weird if I
was like this is amazing a rising Brad
Pitt like then I think people would
think I was a little bit off right so at
the time yeah you're an 11 year old and
you think it's it's just like this gross
thing what I was thinking about is how
weird is it when you did have your first
kiss I don't know mine was when I was 35
I'm guessing yours was earlier I did
eighth grade field trip it was in the
Washington Monument so it was pretty
light but he was a friend and it just
happened with my class in the elevator
and it was dark I don't know if you know
have you been in the elevator to go to
the top in the Washington Monument I've
been in the Washington Mya but I don't
think about it as makeout central well
neither did I I was like oh I'm
surprised I did not expect that at all
that is gutsy of that kid exactly so he
I guess he got the Brad Pitt memo
yeah well wait a minute here's the thing
that I'm curious about how tough is it
for that kid when you say like well
that's actually not my first kiss my
first was with Brad - that's gonna be
tough there was no tongue though at all
I was literally like so like yeah you
know yeah yeah yeah good good no I
didn't think there wasn't you've gotten
something done so many big movies what
are the ones that you get recognized the
most for if you're out and around
definitely spider-man right oh that's
quite a man
well as funny as I went to I was at
Bloomingdale's recently I live in the
valley which is so close to the studio
right um but I was at Fashion Square
Mall and this woman comes up to me I'm
shopping for shoes and she she looks at
me and she like takes my hand she was
like I miss you in films I was like well
she's like I've seen you in the
spider-man movies but why don't we see
you anymore I miss you in movies I was
like oh god I'm like I'm sorry I'm not
in like the thing we didn't make a
fourth movie I've been working I just
maybe you don't live we're making a
Taurani independent theater yeah I'm
sorry like I was like but he made me
feel terrible and also like yeah just
terrible action terrible and terrible
but if she was so sweet - well that's
makes it even worse
yeah I know I was like I want to be like
well the next film I had this Warner
Brothers so maybe she'll be happy well
snow she wants to see killing us - block
block Buster's he wants me to bang it
out like I'm sorry I just you know like
you can't apologize but also I can't
believe how many people when I walk
around people always come up and they
say sand ice people say a lot of nice
things but sometimes people think
they're saying something nice yeah and
it's this I'm always getting like oh yes
you're so I mean you're good-looking in
person much better-looking in person
you're so much better-looking in person
I'm like and then I think what freak is
on the show
I felt that way too I'm like why don't
you like what does she expect that
you're that you're turning down
blockbusters left right I'd be happy to
it I just people think you just like get
me a blockbuster yeah do that every day
your recently quit smoking I did yeah
about a month ago that's supposed to be
that supposed to be the hardest thing
you can do it you know if I went to this
hypnotist guy and you go three times and
it wasn't that hard a hypnotist yes I'm
very skeptical of that I mean really
it's working well it's not like this you
know what I mean he's not like you are
falling asleep it's work he's he takes
little sips of water as he's talking to
you and scaring the living death out of
you and then the second time you go you
quit and then the third time it's just
like to just any concerns or anything
he's hypnotized you but he's just taking
sips of water
yeah and scaring you that would hit me
ties me to never want water yeah how is
he scaring you well he's basically
saying like you're you never know when
you're gonna die of cancer which is a
horrible yeah and the next one could be
your last breath you know what I mean
really so he says that he says that to
you well he just scares the living I'm
sure that yeah but it worked
yeah it worked and I feel so much better
good why do so many people should do
that yeah so terrible for haribol
you